hello my name is busty okung died I'm
with ugc technologies Shanghai China yes
I do think the football is going to take
place here in 2010 is actually very good
for the world cup is very good for not
only South Africa but the entire
continent of Africa first of all is
going to be I president meaning this is
the first time this is coming to Africa
so hopefully we'll be coming again and
it wouldn't be so much of a headache on
me this iconic third or a fourth time to
Africa and in terms of other areas
besides football just the infrastructure
that has been developed for this
activity is football coming to South
Africa is a lot of benefits for the
masses in terms of infrastructure
development is another benefit and is
creating jobs and skills also that are
very well needed not only in south
africa by other parts of Africa but
right now creating it here in South
Africa I think these are very very good
thing and of course when the football
activities itself themselves I head up
here in South Africa there will be
people coming from all over the world
not just from Africa from South Africa
and long and these people are going to
be bringing in a whole lot of what I say
financial stuff that they will compete
and spend in South Africa so that's also
beneficial for South Africa and besides
that there are other things like
follow-up effects that would actually
happen in South Africa so a lot of not
just football relationship will be
happening among all these peoples of the
world but also there are business issues
and friendship issues also cultural
issues that will follow as a result of
these so I think it's very beneficial
not only to South Africa but to the
entire continent